[Musique]
ça c'est moi je m'appelle alex j'ai 35
ans et j'aime me faire larguer voilà
pourquoi mes meilleurs potes ont décidé
de m'emmener en week end à la campagne
par le réalisateur de quescom a fait au
cosmos touristes à bananes à manille
quito 1 2 et 3 cet honneur est là ça
sent vraiment la campagne et de mamies
qui tout à la full moon en thaïlande
c'est vraiment mes meilleurs poteau et
ses copains voulais juste lui changer
les idées mais il allait changer
beaucoup plus pendant que les poteaux ce
réveil j'ai décidé de faire un petit bar
docter copine la gueule il a gardé le
sila pense bien appliqué les saucisses
un oui j'allais oublier
attendez qu'ils me parlent c'est moi
c'est l'assaut si tu veux être mon ami
la saucisse gpp découvrir une histoire
d'amitié sur la tolérance entre un homme
et une saucisse oui vous avez bien
entendu une saucisse jarque est mis avec
une actrice césarisé qui casse son image
en faisant une crise aussi mais c'est
mon ami ok avec un youtuber qui joue mal
mais on s'en fout ça fait l'équipe pour
la bande annonce et bien sûr avec le jus
équipé d'un sa loi
6 une comédie qu barbecue avec la wayne
louis garrel halte à partager sur
facebook
instagram et twitter sna ok ok et quand
pour le truc du nom et du prénom sur la
fiche s'est pas toujours bien passé ok
mon nom de youtube